so if you're at home and you have a
problem with andrew tate okay
okay i've had issues with some of the
stuff he said
you have access to a social media
account anyone can create a channel
right you can create a youtube channel
you can go on ig live you can have a
social media account why don't you tell
people why you think he's a problem
why don't you your parent out there and
you think this is the wrong message for
boys and you've got a son and you're why
don't you tell people why you feel this
isn't the way to go for men
that's how you counter because this
isn't about tate right
that's what people need to understand
banning andrew tate does nothing
it'll do two things actually it will
drive people a more extremist position
into the underground
where it will gather and it will gain
intensity and it will gain heat and it
will manifest i don't know how
but the reality is
whether you like it or not there is a
segment of the male population that has
been drawn to what he's saying
okay they still exist
you can ban him right he's just a guy
he's just a guy
it's not about him
he connected with people in the
population for some reason
is it not worth it to you if you're so
concerned about that message to figure
out why
why is this message appealing is there a
segment of the male population that
has been frustrated in some way by
society by feminism by
by what
what is it
let's talk about it
let's have that conversation right and
maybe there's a segment of the male
population that wants to engage in
really bad behavior toward women and
there and he appeals to them in that
respect
well better to have the mountain
sunlight and let's debate them let's
expose that let's talk about it let's
not drive them into the underground
where they rally around being banned
every single person that is banned comes
out
stronger
look at trump they took him off twitter
did that stop him no
he's more powerful than ever every time
the fbi raid on mar does that no
no
you have a problem with somebody you
have that conversation head on you
invite them i'm not saying tate would go
to everybody's show but you can
certainly pull look what i did i pulled
his commentary and i said this is why
this is wrong
here he may have a point but here's
here's why this is wrong i invited rolo
on the show
who's gonna come back
we had that conversation so just
remember this is not about andrew tate
you think you're going to ban andrew
tate and this is going to stop no like i
said you're going to have to ban
everybody who disseminates his content
if you want to do that what are you just
going to go on a list and ban a whole
bunch of just
people who have no name recognition and
are just why
why not instead assess that something is
wrong right you you decide you don't
like his commentary and that it's
dangerous okay that's step one
instead of banning it take it head on
you're confident in why you think it's
wrong you're confident that you have a
better solution you're confident that
you have a message from men that's more
uplifting
speak it
speak it
let that thrive over what he's saying
that is your weapon your weapon is not
the ban
okay i'm gonna tell you every every
single time
so i saw this and i you know
and and immediately people said oh it's
funny i got messages that said
oh you hate what he says you know you've
brought it to take an issue with him on
the show and i'm sure you're happy to
see him banned no
no and you know why because who's next
who is next i every single time this
happens to somebody you have to know
that you could be next you have to know
that this slippery slope of what is
hateful
and what
what is problematic and what is
misinformation
is decided by who
what is their political ideology is
there an agenda and what is next
so i don't like bands i don't like bands
i don't like bands for people i disagree
with i prefer an invitation to talk to
me
about why we see things differently and
why i have a better way
so tyler what did you think about it
i'll ask you what did you think about
the band
no i agree wholeheartedly uh vic says we
the people are not in the banning
business and i don't think you could
have summed it up any better uh you know
another good one was alex jones that's
been pointed out a few times in the chat
they banned alex jones and look how much
popular he got right that's right trump
jones is that every time right every
single time it will happen
where do you think this ends though
because for for tate i mean i
are they are they gonna now ban
everybody who's a follower of tate i
mean are they gonna ban everyone who
speaks positively and includes a video
is it is it that aggressive or was it
just about taking out the top dog
i think it was just about taking out the
top i would be interested to see what he
posted that got him banned um i don't
know what he would have posted that got
a band i do think it's ironic that tick
tock is banning people we all know what
tick tock is
as far as the ccp goes um but i i really
do think it was just
proving that they have more power than
any force in the world right now tick
tock meta facebook ig all right
it was very much just about taking out
the most popular person on the internet
because that's what he is
like
it's one thing to take out trump right
trump is
it's it's another whole different realm
to take out the most viral person on the
internet they just wiped him clean he's
done um i'm sure he'll be banned from
youtube
oh for sure right and then he's got so i
believe what he does is he has people
that post all his content for him so
you've got andrew tate and then
thousands of channels that post content
so then what happens to those channels
exactly right so
it's going to be interesting to see how
this plays out but again
i mean i don't disagree at all like like
the guy just like the guy i personally
don't like him i don't like what he says
um but don't you don't ban somebody you
just you let him speak and it's it's
uh the market ideas be beat them with
your ideas have a discussion like it's
it's fairly simple and common sensible
to most people we did it here it was so
easy we i pulled up clips i tried to
find context around those clips and i i
offered a better way what i thought was
a better way as someone who has a son
and does not in any way want my child
following the advice of andrew tade if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]